nos encontramos frente a las costas
según las autoridades de la gobernación
de esta provincia de ucrania han
asegurado que desde esta mañana
empezaron ataques de misiles con 14
embarcaciones que se encontrarían en las
costas que están alrededor estos ataques
no habrían sido propiamente a la ciudad
de odessa sino a poblaciones costeras
hemos sentido uno de esos ataques esta
tarde ellos han dicho que dos personas
han muerto pero que la situación sigue
está hablar preguntárseles como podía
desarrollarse ellos nos han dicho que
bueno que todo que en esta guerra todo
cambiaba rápidamente sin embargo aquí en
los alrededores en este paseo marítimo
las personas siguen caminando siguen
paseando con sus perros y lo mismo
sucede en la ciudad donde se vivió un
cierto aire de tranquilidad sin embargo
hay todavía llegando refugiados o
desplazados de otras provincias de las
costas de ucrania y estas personas
tratan de llegar a la estación camino
hacia otras regiones especialmente hacia
está la región de la vid que acoge a
millones de desplazados internos de esta
guerra iniciada por los rusos hace 21
días